comment vous allez je vais vraiment très
bien
je souhaiterais que vous verbalise
yelina comment son suicide vous a
affecté elle a sauté par-dessus
l'échangeur sur l'autoroute et la tv
direct sur la remorque d'un camion et
son cadavre est ensuite resté coincé à
la douane de l'aéroport pendant une
semaine
eh ben bravo nous écarter un peu plus
vos jambes on va pas il est d'abord non
il faut manger les vecteurs à 10 je
mangerai ça dans 5 minutes promis sur la
tombe de ma mère mais votre maman est en
fils
je les nuits 1 vous êtes le mari de li
na waie je suis pas une cinglée enfin
dans le sens habituel
silvana m'a parlé de ton accident je
peux pas te sauver je peux à peine nous
sauvez moi mon gosse mais je te demande
rien du tout
madame bennett et liens de ceux qui vous
demandent foot elle compte séparé
préféré que ce soit moi c'est ce que je
voulais vous dire
certes aucune qu'unité c'est pas grave
vas-y soleil
j'ai vraiment très très très mal parce
que vous voulez aller mieux dit leclaire
oui vraiment